كان المرضى الذين يعانون من عدوى فيروس كورونا
الحادة والذين تعرضوا لتضخم
البطين الأيمن للقلب هم الأكثر
عرضة للوفاة من المرض بناءً على
بيانات من دراسة جديدة قام فريق من
كلية الطب في إيكان Mount Sinai
بفحص السجلات الصحية لأكثر من
100 kovat 19  المرضى الذين تم إدخالهم إلى المستشفى في
Mount Sinai Morningside في مدينة نيويورك
بين 26 مارس و 22 أبريل 31٪ لديهم
اتساع في البطين الأيمن
41٪ ماتوا بنهاية فترة الدراسة
مقارنة بـ 11٪ من أولئك الذين
لم تتضخم البطين الأيمن لديهم
تم قبوله للنشر
في مجلة الكلية
الأمريكية لأمراض القلب تقول إن تضخم البطين الأيمن
كان المتغير الوحيد
المرتبط بشكل كبير بالوفيات
في هذه المجموعة من مرضى كوفات 19 ،
والسبب وراء النتائج الجديدة لا يزال
غير معروف
يمكن أن يكون تضخم البطين الأيمن بسبب  وفقًا لمؤلفي الدراسة الجديدة ، انسداد
تدفق الدم في الرئتين بسبب
جلطات الدم أو تلف أنسجة الرئة
يقولون إن
الضرر المباشر الذي أصاب أنسجة القلب بسبب
فيروس كورونا قد يكون أيضًا عاملاً مساهماً
الآن أحد الأشياء التي واجهتها هو أن
الناس يأتون إلي ويقولون الكثير من
الأشياء اللطيفة ولكن أيضًا لا
تحتاج إلى قناع ، فأنت حصلت على الأجسام المضادة التي يمتلكها
الجميع  بالحديث عن اختبارات الأجسام المضادة
والأمل في الحصول عليها ، رأيت هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين كانوا مستائين جدًا والذين قالوا إنك
تعلم أنني امتلكت الأجسام المضادة ثم
أعيد اختبارها ولم أعد أمتلكها بعد الآن
، فهل سأمرض ما الذي نعرفه
عن هؤلاء  تختبر موثوقيتها
وما يقولونه حول المكان الذي نريد
المضي قدمًا فيه ، نعم أعتقد أنه من
الصعب الإيمان كثيرًا بالاختبارات في
الوقت الحالي ، وذلك
لسببين أولاً وقبل كل شيء سأقول إن
شخصًا مثلك هو  مررت بهذا
، من المحتمل أن يكون لديك أجسام مضادة ، أعني
أن الاختبارات قد تجدها في بعض الأحيان قد
لا تكون لديك في أوقات أخرى
، وربما تمنحك درجة معينة
من الحماية ، ولا نعرف إلى أي
مدى تمكنا من معرفة ذلك
بقدر ما تذهب الاختبارات نفسها ، هناك
نقطتان ، الأولى هي أن هناك الكثير من
الاختبارات التي تم طرحها في السوق
6070 اختبارًا لم يتم التحقق من صحتها
ربما لم يكن اختبارًا جيدًا للغاية ، كان هناك
هذا الاندفاع لإجراء الاختبارات هناك الآن
إنهم يطلبون ذلك مرة أخرى ويحاولون
العودة والتحقق من صحة بعض هذه الاختبارات
ولكن هناك مشكلة أكثر دقة ، كريس
إذا رأيت ما إذا كان بإمكاني شرح ذلك في
مجتمع لا يوجد
فيه الكثير من الأشخاص الذين لديهم أجسام مضادة
لديك  خمسة إلى عشرة بالمائة من الأشخاص
لديهم أجسام مضادة يصعب العثور عليها ،
ونتيجة لذلك ، تقوم نوعًا ما من قوة اختباراتك
للعثور عليها وتفقد ما يسمى
بقيمتك التنبؤية الإيجابية ، إنه
مصطلح إحصائي ولكنه يعني بشكل أساسي
أنك تخاطر الآن  الحصول على الكثير من
الإيجابيات الكاذبة وهو أسوأ
سيناريو لا تريده أن تخبر الناس
أن لديهم الأجسام المضادة ولا يفعلون ذلك
لأن لديهم هذا الشعور الزائف
بالأمان على الرغم من أنه لا ينبغي لهم ذلك
لأنك تحصل على المزيد من الأشخاص الذين  نكون
يتعرض العاملون في مجال الرعاية الصحية على سبيل المثال في نيويورك ، حيث سيصبح عدد أكبر من الأشخاص الذين تعرضوا للاختبار في الواقع ، فإن دقة الموثوقية إذا كنت سترتفع في الاختبار بحيث يكون لديك المزيد من الأشخاص المعرضين لهذا الفيروس فكرة أنك سوف نحدد بشكل صحيح أولئك الذين لديهم أجسام مضادة بأن الاحتمال سيرتفع نحن لسنا هناك بعد في هذه المرحلة ، لذلك شخص مثلك يعرف أنك عالق نوعًا ما في طي النسيان ، فأنت تعلم أن لديك أجسامًا مضادة لا تعرف مدى حمايتها هناك الكثير من الأشخاص يذهبون ويخضعون للاختبار في الوقت الحالي ، ولن يحصلوا على نتيجة اختبار ستمنحهم الثقة التي تعرفها والأشياء التي تعرفها وسيظلون يتساءلون عما إذا كان لدي الآن أعيد فتح جميع الولايات الخمسين إلى حد ما ، وبينما يحذر الخبراء من أن التحرك بسرعة كبيرة قد يؤدي إلى تسريع جائحة كوفات 19 ، يتساءل الكثيرون عما إذا كان من الآمن زيارة الشركات ، تذكر أن ترتدي قناعًا كثيرًا يغسل أو يعقم  nds في أي خدمة تلمسها وتبقى على بعد
ستة أقدام من
الآخرين ، إليك بعض النصائح الأخرى. 1
لا تخرج مثل يوم عادي من
مكان إلى آخر ، حدد نزهاتك في
عمل واحد - إذا كنت ترغب في تناول العشاء في
مطعم  حاول أن تأكل
خارج الفيروس ينتشر أكثر في
الأماكن المغلقة تأكد من أنك على بعد ستة أقدام من
الطاولات الأخرى واغسل يديك
قبل وبعد تناول 3 عند التوجه إلى
الشاطئ أو المتنزه تحية على الإرشادات والقيود الحالية
لن تسمح بعض الأماكن إلا  ستكون متواجدًا إذا واصلت
التحرك وإذا كان مزدحمًا ابحث عن
مكان آخر لتشعر أنك بحاجة
إلى التعرق جيدًا في صالة الألعاب الرياضية أولاً
تأكد من أنك بعيد عن الآخرين
امسح كل آلة أو قطعة من
المعدات قبل الاستخدام وبعده  ترغب 5
في الحصول على قصة شعر أو باديكير في حين
أنه من المستحيل التباعد الاجتماعي مع
الموظفين في أماكن مثل هذه ، فهناك
بعض الأشياء التي يمكنك فعلها بقراءة بروتوكولات السلامة الخاصة
بهم للتأكد من أنهم يتخذون
كل خطوة للقضاء على
المخاطر  أنا حول التباعد الاجتماعي الآن ، أصبحت
تقنية التضمين في Waukesha في
طليعة وكان يوم الجمعة يتحدث إلى هيئة
النقل في مدينة نيويورك
، وبينما كنت أتحدث
معهم ، وصفت البحرية الأمريكية أنهم
مهتمون بتضمين النموذج الأولي للتكنولوجيا من أجل
تباعد اجتماعي يمكن ارتداؤه  راقب
الزوج مرتبًا ، نضع تنبيهًا
حتى يهتز عندما تكون على بعد ستة
أقدام من شخص آخر ،
هذه التقنية دقيقة في حدود
بوصة إلى بوصتين ، لكن هذا يمكن أن يساعد في
تدريب السلوك بشكل صحيح للغاية كما
لم أفعل  لم أدرك أن هذا كان قريبًا
تمامًا تمامًا والناس يعرفون أنهم
يخضعون للمراقبة ،
لذا إذا كانت القواعد في ألستون ، فلا
تقترب من ستة أقدام من شخص
ما وفجأة تعلم أن البيانات تظهر أنه
كل خمس دقائق  ذهبت للحديث مع
كل شخص حصلت عليه على بعد ثلاثة
أقدام من كل شخص في المبنى
والذي يعرض الجميع للخطر كما
أن عنصر الإنذار الاجتماعي
هو تضمين التكنولوجيا التي تقول إنها تتبع جهة الاتصال
الجزء الذي يمكن أن يثبت أنه أكثر
أهمية ، فهو سيحافظ فقط على استمرار
السجل ، وبعد ذلك إذا كانت هناك مشكلة
مريضة لشخص ما ، فيمكنه سحب هذا
الجهاز وسحب تتبع
جهات الاتصال التي تعرف أنه من
المحتمل أيضًا تضمينها في
معرفات الكلية التي تساعد في احتواء حالة العطاء البيئي
19 موجودة في الحرم الجامعي ، لذا يمكن أن يكون هذا
جزءًا واحدًا من هذا اللغز يمكنهم
معرفة من كان الطلاب قد انخرطوا
معه في الأيام العشرة الماضية
أو أي فترة يريدون النظر
فيها  أداة مهمة للغاية في
السيطرة على انتشار الفيروس التاجي